Estábamos emocionados con estos resultados pero luego Jim se puso de pie,
y lo que ocurrió fue realmente notable.
Toda la biomecánica natural mediada por el sistema nervioso central
emergió a través de la extremidad sintética
como una acción involuntaria y reflexiva.
Las complejidades de la colocación de los pies durante el ascenso de la escalera
(Aplausos)
surgió ante nuestros ojos.
Aquí está Jim descendiendo pasos,
llegando con su dedo biónico a la siguiente banda de rodamiento,
exhibiendo automáticamente movimientos naturales
sin él, incluso tratando de mover su extremidad.
Dado que el sistema nervioso de Jim recibe las señales propioceptivas,
sabe exactamente cómo controlar la extremidad sintética de forma natural.
Ahora, Jim se mueve y se comporta como si la extremidad sintética fuera parte de él.
Por ejemplo, un día en el laboratorio,
accidentalmente pisó un rollo de cinta aislante.
Ahora, ¿qué haces cuando algo está pegado a tu zapato?
No alcanzas abajo así; es demasiado incómodo
En cambio, lo sacudes,
y eso es exactamente lo que hizo Jim
después de estar conectado neuronalmente a la extremidad por unas pocas horas.
Lo que fue más interesante para mí
es lo que Jim nos estaba diciendo que estaba experimentando.
Él dijo: "El robot se convirtió en parte de mí".
Jim Ewing: La mañana después de la primera vez que estuve apegado al robot,
mi hija bajó y me preguntó cómo era ser un ciborg,
y mi respuesta fue que no me sentía como un ciborg.
Sentí que tenía mi pierna,
y no era que estuviera apegado al robot
tanto como el robot estaba conectado a mí,
y el robot se convirtió en parte de mí.
Se convirtió en mi pierna bastante rápido.
Hugh Herr: Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Al conectar bidireccionalmente el sistema nervioso de Jim
a su extremidad sintética,
hemos hecho posible una manifestación neurológica.
Mi hipótesis de que, dado que Jim puede pensar y mover su extremidad sintética,
y puede sentir esos movimientos dentro de su sistema nervioso,
la prótesis ya no es una herramienta separada,
sino una parte integral de Jim, una parte integral de su cuerpo.
Debido a esta encarnación neurológica, Jim no se siente como un ciborg.
Siente que recuperó su pierna,
que recuperó su cuerpo.
A menudo me preguntan cuándo voy a estar vinculado neuronalmente
a mis extremidades sintéticas en forma bidireccional,
cuando voy a convertirme en un ciborg.
La verdad es que dudo de convertirme en un ciborg.
Antes de que me amputaran las piernas, era un estudiante terrible.
Obtuve malas notas en la escuela.
Más tarde, después de la amputación de mis extremidades,
de repente me convertí en profesor de MIT.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Mi preocupación es que una vez que esté conectado a mis extremidades nuevamente,
mi cerebro vuelva al camino de un yo no tan brillante.
(Risa)
Pero saben qué, está bien, porque en MIT ya me contrataron.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Creo que el alcance del diseño NeuroEmbodied
se extenderá más allá del reemplazo de extremidades
y llevará a la humanidad a dominios
que fundamentalmente redefinen el potencial humano.
En este siglo XXI,
los diseñadores extenderán el sistema nervioso a exoesqueletos muy fuertes
que los humanos podamos controlar y sentir con la mente.
Los músculos dentro del cuerpo se pueden reconfigurar
para controlar motores potentes,
y para tratar de sentir los movimientos del exoesqueleto,
aumentar la fuerza humana, el salto de altura y la velocidad de carrera.
En este siglo XXI, creo que los humanos nos convertiremos en superhéroes.
Los humanos también podemos extender nuestros cuerpos
con estructuras no antropomórficas, como alas,
controlando y sintiendo cada movimiento de ala dentro del sistema nervioso.
Leonardo da Vinci dijo: "Una vez que hayas probado el vuelo,
siempre caminarás por la tierra con tus ojos vueltos hacia el cielo,